hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round two of this
year's Shak Bundesliga it is NRE abdat
who just finished the tournament that
was the katar Masters he almost won
first place he had to go into tibre
against um his teammate also from from
usbekistan also nbe yakubu and he he he
lost in the tie breaks and here he faces
Thomas bson uh who already featured on
the channel I think twice but this is
the first time that we are featuring him
as a grandm so far we've only had him as
an international Master he won his
grandmas title uh this year in June and
this is a beautiful game of beautiful
King hunt and the mistake that allowed
it is uh too complicated to uh to
explain while I'm showing you the game
so I will go back to it after the game
so stay tuned for that as well it's a
really complicated U maneuver so let's
check it out Notre Beck has the white
pieces and he opens with E4 we have C5
Thomas goes for the Sicilian defense
Knight F3 and E6 going for the French
variation of the Sicilian D4 captures
captures and now Knight to C6 we have
Knight to C3 and Knight to F6 so all
standard stuff nothing new here the Tano
variation Bishop to E2 with have a
bishop to B4 now pinning the Knight here
and castles Bishop captures on C3 B
captures and now Knight captures on e4 H
we have Knight captures on C6 D captures
on C6 and now Bishop to D3 offering the
C3 pawn and while you can capture it
it's nothing fancy as Queen H5 is really
annoying black cannot Castle you don't
want to play G6 otherwise you're going
to weaken your Pawn structure you could
play H6 but this will also weaken your
Pawn structure and you play something
like Queen F6 then comes Bishop to G5
and if Queen to D4 you continue sorry uh
developing Rook F D1 uh and still black
has to decide how to play this probably
Bishop D7 maybe a castle Queen side H
it's uh uh you know not worth the hassle
for this double the c c Pawn so here
Knight to C5 this is the standard move
in the position uh and now Queen to G4
there is a game where Bishop to A3 was
played sort of an idea to force black to
capture on D3 you UND double your pawns
and you sort of keep the black king in
the center of the board uh but F6 will
be played King to F7 Rook to E8 and it's
actually perfectly fine for black maybe
even better so instead after Knight to
C5 Queen to G4 this is the main attempt
we have Queen to F6 and now Bishop to G5
attacking the queen queen captures on C3
and now there are a couple of games that
reach this position for example Rook a
to D1 is a know move uh but here we have
Queen to G3 and it is now as of move 13
that we have a completely new game the
threat of course is if um if Thomas cast
Bishop captures on H7 check picks up the
queen and C3 so that's the idea behind
the que tricky Queen to G3 move so
Knight captures on D3 eliminating the
strong bishop and now not captures with
the pawn or with the queen now comes
Rook 8 D1 this was the plan H because
now if you try to save the Knight let's
say go Knight E5 Rook to d8 is just
Checkmate so the Knight will hang and
you will get the dile for your Rook
maybe even double up on the dile so
Queen to C5 and now Rook captures on D3
with have Pawn to F6 challenging the
bishop now Rook F to D1 uh again you
cannot capture uh the bishop on G5
because Rook d8 check will pick up the
Rook on h8 so here we have castles and
now Bishop to H6 Notre backck now
threatens Checkmate on G7 so Queen back
to E7 uh and now look at this Rook to d8
beautiful beautiful Rook lift point of
course is that you cannot capture twice
as the queen is stuck here guarding the
G7 pawn and now the mistake that I've uh
mentioned at the beginning of the video
uh happens right here and the point is
here you can play B6 you can play B5 you
can uh uh you can play some moves but
you cannot play C5 C5 is a pawn that
should remain on C6 and why we're going
to discuss after the game so here Pawn
to C5 uh it's a crucial mistake that
loses the game uh so even feel free to
pause the video and figure out how to
take advantage of this while I give you
a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh
realizing the mistake behind Pawn to C5
and also how to take advantage of
Black's position as black really can't
move a piece there's really nothing you
can do uh point being that even if you
played B6 you still cannot play Bishop
to B7 because Rook to D7 would put too
much pressure on G7 so you can't move
the queen you can't move the Rook you
can't really move anything but uh there
were better moves than uh C5 and the way
you punish it is Pawn to H4 uh now the
the idea is fairly simple it's H5 you're
going to Capt on G7 and then uh well the
idea is that black just doesn't have any
moves there's nothing black can play
here uh Thomas played Pawn to B5 now
comes Pawn to H5 and now after Pawn to
E5 opening up the light Square Bishop uh
just Bishop captures on G7 so what are
you going to play here Queen captures on
G7 now Rook captures on f8 forcing the
black king to capture King captures on
f8 and now Rook to d8 with check you
cannot go to E7 the queen would hang so
queen king to F7 and now Queen to B3
with check C4 doesn't do anything as you
will capture on B5 and again h no way to
no way to avoid everything here this is
a threat Queen to D D5 is a threat um
there's no move that helps you here so
instead after Queen to B3 check King to
E7 was played and now Queen to D5
putting pressure on The Rook but also uh
just threatening Queen to D6 check which
is even more potent so Queen to H6
hoping that notbe grabs The Rook on A8
but of course he doesn't he plays Queen
to D6 with check King to F7 and now Pawn
to F4 a beautiful move that you just
throw in in the middle of the attack uh
simply to mess with any plans that black
might have of defending the position
like maybe some sort of a Perpetual with
Queen to C1 check in the future uh
because if Queen captures now now you
will of course deliver a check Queen to
f8 check and now you just pick up the
queen uh King here Rook to D6 check King
five and Rook captures on F6 will win
the black queen and you don't even get
to enjoy your bishop and Rook because
after Queen to D6 there's no way to play
this will either win The Rook or if you
play Bishop B7 then this wins the bishop
so H black will be left with either a
bishop or a rook versus a queen so of
course completely winning for white so e
captures on F4 was played instead but
now Queen to C7 with check King to E6
and now Queen to C6 with check now uh if
you go to to F7 then it's a very quick
Checkmate Queen to E8 with check King to
G7 and queen to E7 this will be
Checkmate the pawn of course covers the
G6 Square so if uh King to F5 which was
played in the game now comes Queen to D5
with check again the pawn covering G6 is
very important uh that's why H4 H5 was
so crucial for the attack King to G4
Rook to G8 with check uh we have King to
H4 and now there is uh well there are
many moves that win the game but there
is one that ends the game on the spot
and of course notbe played it pawn to G3
with check uh opening up this diagonal
Queen to H1 will be Checkmate as The
Rook controls this um uh this G file
okay not right away you might be able to
to block with the bishop but it doesn't
matter really uh what you do the point
is is if um sorry if F captures on G3
then Queen to E4 check now you cannot
block with the bishop or you get
checkmated so King captures an H5 now
Queen to H1 with check and after you um
put the bishop to H3 just Queen captures
on H3 will be Checkmate but uh uh Thomas
did not allow this he uh he allowed an
even quicker Checkmate he just played
King to H3 and here Queen to H1 was um
uh sorry Queen to G2 was Checkmate and
that's how nicely Norbeck won this game
now just quickly to go back to that
position where we discussed why C C5 is
such a mistake so uh like I said let's
play B5 instead as it's a move that
Thomas also played but after C5 now why
doesn't the same idea work because okay
black cannot move anything we already I
found that but let's see H4 A5 and now
H5 everything the same E5 and now uh
what does Bishop captures on G7 dud the
move that Notre used to win the game
Bishop captures Queen captures Rook
captures King captures and now Rook to
d8 with check everything the same King
to F7 and now Queen to B3 with check
King to E7 is the move you now have that
you didn't have in the line that Thomas
played because now the pawn is on C6 uh
you do not have Queen to D5 that's the
uh that's the big difference so uh very
very very tricky stuff but I mean if you
see this I mean good for you but uh here
without being able to move a piece I
mean you're happy to even find a move
like C5 uh and I guess okay maybe you
could argue that B6 or B5 is a bit more
logical as it will allow you to somehow
develop your light Square Bishop but
like we said the bishop is never moving
from this diagonal as Rook to D7 would
just be unstoppable so this is unless
you really really know how to play this
by heart uh because it's a the the
position is dead draw uh obviously Notre
backck prepared it very well if you
don't know it your opponent will blunder
so maybe it's a nice line for you guys
to learn uh if you if you uh play
against the Sicilian a lot if you play
against the ton of Sicilian uh maybe you
know a couple of nice tricks and a
couple of of very very uh crafty moves
like Queen to G3 and then uh you know
bringing the Rook to D1 with Tempo is
there is Checkmate on d8 so I'm sure you
can take something from this game and
use it in your own games uh so that's
the game very nicely done by Notre
backck who not only almost won the
cutter Masters but now just continues
playing incredible chess and just
crushing U uh newly appointed Grand
Masters like this uh so yeah once again
really hope you enjoyed it hope it
improved your Sunday somewhat I would
like to thank Chad Smith Sam's giant
Tais Farm gumati morti Anonymous person
and Daniel Taylor for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and uh I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World H so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and what what did you
think about the fight yesterday
volkanovski versus Mev uh what a what
what a miniature huh uh incredible stuff
uh see you
soon